c'est vrai et et c'est vrai quoi la
tonnelle a fait macro avec mâcon où il
parle vous êtes beaucoup en contact avec
le président ah oui ça fait deux ans que
nous correspondant par sms et vous vous
dites quoi
alors là on vous voit robin seul ménage
pas la lui dis toi les ménages par dans
ses rêves ou le ménage et par an vous
lui dites quoi ah ben je parle j'ai tout
de tout ce qui fait de ce que c'est vous
les 4 kilomètres heure sur les autres
stades
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
ces boules et katia 80 km heure sur les
routes nationales c'est pas mal au
classement
non non c'est vrai j'ai voulu donner des
conseils vous l'avez vous la donner des
conseils sur les gilet jaune
enfin il paraît que vous avez des
conseils sur les gilets jaunes
je fais d'ailleurs vd j'ai fait des
observations sont tout ce qui se passe
et tous les événements qui se passent
sous lui dit quoi par exemple pas par
exemple je lui dis que j'espère que la
pma sera pas voté parce que je pense
qu'il est content d'avoir appert que
brigitte des enfants ayant un père et
quand on veut faire une loi pour dire
que la naissance l'enfant n'aura pas de
père à la demande des lesbiennes bas je
pense que ça ne peut pas marcher
voilà non mais là où ça fait quoi entre
est ouvert aux jeunes viennent je le
vivrais lui ai dit je vais écrire non
mais ça dit d'ailleurs il n'est pas très
très très n'est pas bien vous éviterez
défaut faut vivre avec votre ton cia
deux femmes non pro d2 c'est la
filiation de façon innée travées de
l'éden genèse du donneur de quatre il ya
des enfants qui ont deux papas ou deux
mamans qui sont très anormal mais à
faire les loutres et rire à un enfant
qui leur a pas tort en et saint eloi la
seule chose dont a besoin un enfant lui
dire tout de suite qu'il a pas
on attend des trucs à la con alors être
d'accord avec moi c'est non geneviève
geneviève dalle va pas être d'accord
avec toi geneviève sur votre micro je
devienne je te jure qu'il ya des enfants
qui ont dopé mais bien sûr mais on ne
dit pas quand même la naissance à un
enfant on fait une loi pour peta deux
fils qui n'est pas de pair voyons c'est
pas normal
ah bon après après la ville pas en avoir
mais partira au désir à l'un des sièges
quand même tu nous diras coursimault
c'est bon on peut débattre jeunes vise à
débattre
gibrat ça y est vous ah oui je suis
lesbienne qui peut pas le peuple voilà
elles veulent pas avoir un mec dans
ledit pour faire un bébé
allons chercher une seconde et puis on
puis voilà pas mal aussi à 3 ans il
était à l'école péguy les dents
missionnaire à vos débats et après la
fia pâle et et amis the last resort du
façon à 18 ans il pourra chercher son
père parce qu'ils se sont alors allés
des normes que je l'avais su je pense
gilles jill est ce que voulait dire
geneviève caricature a bien sûr et
salades desserts parce qu'elle a une
vision beaucoup plus posé beaucoup plus
intelligente
geneviève franchement écouter ce qu'on a
à dire aussi je vous en prie asseyez
vous et on n'est pas d'accord et qu'elle
a oui là c'est vrai que nos motivations
ce que je sais c'est jusqu'à 9 heures
précises et non mais vous dites on vous
dira dans geneviève parce que j'ai là tu
vas tu mcg pas de salaire j'ai dépassé
le bovin de bief du juste pour vous dire
un mot parce que j'ai une affection
j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour vous je
valais j'ai beaucoup d'affection pour
vous aussi beaucoup vu et j'ai beaucoup
d'affection pour le voilà juste pour des
rameaux hmm hmm hmm quand vous dites et
je peux même quand vous dites quand il
ya deux lesbiennes
c'est tellement péjoratif et sa wii
s'est fait jour arrive dire qu'on est de
lesbiennes effet pas contre non mais de
là à exiger l'étude qui exhibe n'attend
pas la regarder secondes voilà et j'en
ai voulu garder une personne qu'il faut
que j'en ai moi là-bas au parti vous
partez qu'est ce que quelqu'un a quelque
chose à dire à genève mais on vous aime
quand même et ouvrir un tout petit peu
votre esprit mais je faisais le jeune
homme attend mais
non mais non mais bon mes jeunes -
geneviève moi je vous dirais qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui pensent comme
moi oui bien sûr c'est clair il ya des
gens qui pensent comme vous après il ya
d'autres personnes la grosse
différemment voilà c'est tour des droits
de lutter mais pas pour faire une loi
la fille mabelle des nordiques sans
drame a demandé à ta d'affaires un tas
de choses que j'ai rien si sa maison
mais on est en train de le faire là mais
non c'était jusqu'à 9 e non mais non mon
encore à l'antenne là tu sais mais non
mais je dois pas à 9 heures c'était
prévu que ce à quoi faire là je rentre
chez moi
ah c'est pas grave mais il ya quelque
chose qu'il quitte qui n'a pas marché
c'est autant te dire tu as pas marre
comme comme on l'a présenté
c'est quoi que je devais faire si
geneviève elle elle doit elle doit
rentrer merci je te fais un bisou à tu
vois que tu fais mais été bloqué on va
arranger on a rangé à les
applaudissements pour gérard boesch
bon là c'est geneviève dont la rode
accepte qu'elle parte un peu avant will
not least on pense tout bas
j'ai rien compris moi j'adorais ma grand
mère elle avait des idées parfois très
trop bien sûr bel 20 96 ans et nos
sexualités la vie du mal à le comprendre
et pourtant je l'aimais comme ma mère
donc voilà c'est juste que je peux juste
dire aux gens qu'il se fasse pas
j'espère il ya différentes va laisser ça
y est voilà les personnes qui sont
souvent plus âgés ont été éduqués 10h et
il ya aussi des jeunes qui pensent ne
pas lasser les voilà voilà c'est juste
elle avait pas une idée forte et elle a
été très déçu quand j'étais quand ce
débat et sa grand mère et je l'aimé plus
que tout mais elle avait 96 ans et
parfois le monde avance un peu plus vite
que les gens voilà c'est ça non mais
c'est vrai c'est bien de dire avec la
version mathieu bravo le dire merci